et
[Musique]
cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous toma
sam temps bonjour bonjour et bienvenue
sur ce plateau vous êtes réalisateur et
vous avez présenté il ya quelques
semaines à cannes votre dernier film
qu'ils savent qu'ils s'appellent fort de
side of peace au nom de la paix un
documentaire un genre qu'on voit peu au
festival international du cinéma on va
regarder quelques images et on en
reparle juste après
[Musique]
conçu pour des
escroqueries
animaux sociaux de
[Musique]
mesure des
arrivées borloo
ministre denis saverot ce terrain là
tous les bras des systèmes
automatisés
fabricant tricolore
[Musique]
vous avez réalisé co réalisé ce film
avec christophe kastein ce film nous
emmène dans un pays passait complètement
sous les radars médiatiques le soudan du
sud c'est l'un des plus jeunes et des
plus violents pays du monde un pays dit
vous en guerre avec lui même oui c'est
un pays qui tient indépendant depuis
2011 et qui très rapidement ensuite deux
ans plus tard en 2013 est entré en
guerre civile une guerre civile qui a
duré qui a perduré jusqu'en 2018 ou un
premier cessez-le-feu était installé ce
qui a rendu le la réalisation de ce film
assez compliqué ce qui a fait qu'on a dû
mettre six ans pour réaliser pour
réaliser ce documentaire on va revenir
sur les conditions de tournage le soudan
est l'un des pays du monde dans lequel
les déplacés sont le pli noms les plus
nombreux c'est ce que dit encore le
dernier rapport du hcr qui a été publié
aujourd'hui justement plus de 2 millions
de soudanais sont réfugiés à l'étranger
près d'un million vivent aujourd'hui et
dans des camps et c'est quand vous
l'avez vu ils sont partout dans le pays
oui oui on a tourné peut-être sur les
six années qui ont fait le film on a
tourné peut-être un mois un mois et demi
dans un camp de réfugiés un des plus
gros à djouba la capitale tenus par
l'onu oui voilà exactement où on a été
en contact avec gadjo gains des héros de
notre film et ça a été à une expérience
assez délicate pour moi déjà d'aller sur
dans un camp de réfugiés
voir comment la vie s'organisait comment
les gens survivent et dans ces
conditions là et
oui ça a été assez assez délicat mais de
voir derrière ce film on va revenir dans
un instant sur les effectivement les
deux sud-soudanais que vous suivez il y
à une star hollywoodienne l'acteur
forest whitaker
expliquez nous pourquoi il s'intéresse à
ceux à ce pays et à ses enjeux en fait
insulter coeur s'intéressent à ce pays
il a donc une ong qui s'appelle dab
lipides ian whittaker peace and
development initiative qui existe depuis
bientôt dizaine d'années et qui agit
dans des pays qui sont souvent ravagé ou
du mois
gangréné par la guerre la guerre civile
et il essaye de expliquer aux jeunes
tout l'intérêt qu'ils ont d'être des
pistes médiateurs et des
voiles à des médiateurs pour la paix et
justement le parti pris de ce film c'est
de traiter les choses du côté de la
vertu et de la lumière et pour ça vous
suivez deux personnages gatland donc
vous l'avez évoqué à l'instant et non
des gays eu de nom connu quasiment que
la guerre dans leur vie lui est arbitre
de foot dans le camp de déplacés que
vous évoquez à l'instant elle a les
médiatrices elle a pas vraiment le
physique de l'emploi on va peut-être et
revenir et tous les deux et
effectivement ils oeuvrent pour la paix
dans leur pays à leur façon oui c'est ça
c'est deux jeunes personnalités qui
étaient très fortes qui nous aura
intéressé dès le départ parce que
au-delà de au delà des conditions de vie
qu'ils ont tous le disais 'mon quelque
chose de très intéressant à savoir non
des gays qui est une jeune fille assez
jeune qui a eu 25 25 ans qui
fument force de caractère est quelqu'un
de 2 c'était la rose en la voyant voilà
c'est ça je pense que j'ai regardé c'est
quelqu'un qui émanent quelques quelque
chose de très très fort et qui néanmoins
une simplicité aussi en elle et qui qui
qui enfin un personnage formidable à
suivre une faille d'une fille de très
fort caractère est ce qu'elle arrive à
faire et c'est le sujet des images qu'on
voit derrière nous alors que c'est un
petit bout de femme effectivement c'est
qu'elle arrive à réconcilier avec
d'autres médiateurs deux clans qui sont
en conflit depuis des décennies autour
de l'un des maux qui rongent le soudan
du sud le vol de bétail que précisément
les accords de paix que vous au palais
dont vous parliez tout à l'heure signé
en 2018 ne parviennent pas vraiment à
endiguer il faut savoir que le bétail
vraiment les vaches c'est une ressource
très importante là bas ça permet de de
pouvoir se marier c'est c'est une scène
des richesses les plus importants du
pays donc c'est les les des tribus qui
s'affrontent pour ce volet du bétail cd
chose de très très courant là bas qui
font des malheureusement des milliers de
victimes chaque année ouais voilà parce
que parce que ces tribus sont armés et
vont voler le bêta est l'une de l'autre
et ce qu'elle arrive à faire à cette
jeune femme c'est qu'elle arrive à se
faire rencontrer les deux chefs de
tribus de clans en tout cas et qui
finissent par par faire la paix alors il
ya ce petit bout de femme effectivement
et puis une grande liane gants zhang qui
lui donc vit depuis une dizaine d'années
je crois dans ce camp de réfugiés c'est
lui derrière nous avec ce maillot jaune
et lui il pense qu'être arbitre de foot
dans le stade enfin pas vraiment le
stade ils ont deux le terrain du camp de
réfugiés peut permettre d'une certaine
façon d'apprendre aux jeunes sud
soudanais à vivre ensemble oui c'est une
autre façon de faire la paix ça qui est
intéressant aussi c'est ya la façon de
faire la paix d'une manière très qu'on
peut tous se l'imaginé réconcilier de
personnes qui dans le cas de l'endiguer
s'entretuent de tribus qui s'entretuent
et là c'est une autre façon de faire la
paix c'est via les valeurs du sport et
c'est ça qui est aussi intéressant dans
ce final c'est de mettre en parallèle de
deux situations qui évoque la paix une
très concrètes et une autre plus plus
symbolique on va dire faire la paix à
prendre l'appel via les valeurs du sport
et enclenche du football qui sont acquis
un sport que tout le monde connaît et
c'est ça qui rend le qui rend la chose
encore plus agréable à regarder c'est
que tout le monde connaît le foot tout
le monde sait ce que et on voit que dans
ce camp de réfugiés et où où les
conditions sont terribles il ya ce
terrain y as ce jeu-là ce foot qui
permet aux jeunes d'espérer peut-être un
monde meilleur et comme le dit guy zhang
à un moment donné quand ils sortiront du
camp et peut-être que ce qu'ils auront
appris au camp de réfugiés leur servira
ils retrouveront ce même sport qui les a
aidé à survivre dans cette période
difficile qu'il traverse et ça ce film
leur rappellent s'il le fallait encore
la force absolument incroyable du
football on est donc dans un camp de
réfugiés vraiment perdu au milieu du
soudan du sud et au bout d'un moment il
se met à parler des dehors de leur
joueur préféré du marssacois qui est à
des milliers de kilomètres de là sans
savoir que vraiment le camp il ya vingt
mille personnes qui vivent dans un très
petit espace et tout le monde et vie les
uns sur les autres et au milieu il ya ce
terrain de foot qui est un espèce de
poumons noisy ce commune voilà une oasis
où les joueurs où les jeunes peuvent
vivre et rêver quelque chose d'extérieur
etc c'est assez fort ça
oui je pense que c'est dans le film
d'ailleurs c'est un des enjeux à un
moment donné on leur dit est ce que vous
pouvez
arrêter de faire du voudrait récupérer
le terrain de foot pour mettre des
tentes à la place parce qu'il ya trop de
réfugiés qui arrivent à ce que ça vous
dérange pas si enfin voilà on demande à
ce qu'on supprime le terrain de foot et
on voit que c'est impossible pour eux
c'est pas possible de lâcher ça vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure quelques
mots de vos conditions de tournage vous
et que vous avez mis six ans à faire ce
film alors on sait qu'un documentaire ça
prend toujours beaucoup dans six ans
c'est beaucoup parce qu'elles ont été
compliqués en termes de sécurité vous
étiez donc dans ce pays ravagé par la
guerre civile et je crois aussi qu en
termes de en termes de langue en termes
de dialectes ça a été assez compliqué ça
a été un film qui a été compliqué à
monter à tourner du début à la fin c'est
à dire sur les conditions de tournage là
on parle d'un pays qui est à l'époque on
filmait été le deuxième pays le plus
violent du monde juste ans juste après
la syrie donc mettre en place un
tournage dans des conditions de guerre
civile c'est très très compliqué ce qui
a rendu vraiment tournage complexe de
dire qu'on ne pouvait pas tourner ce
qu'on voulait parce que on risquer notre
vie
au détour d'une rue ou à si on
s'éloignait un peu trop d des endroits
où on avait repéré ça c'était évident
donc ça ça à courant du tournage très
compliqué ça l'a suspendu pendant des
années parce que ce qu'on voulait
justement montré une action de paix très
concrète entre deux tribus qui s'entre
tuer pour du bétail cette action là on
voulait la filmer mais elle était à
l'extérieur dans des endroits qui était
très difficilement accessible donc il a
fallu attendre qu'ils ne paient assez
relative pour pouvoir y accéder ce qui
fait que les images là de réconciliation
de paix elles ont été tournées en 2019
et le film qu'on a commencé vraiment
avec zhang a tourné en 2016 il a fallu
trois ans pour attendre les conditions
des puits saint vite tourné beaucoup de
ça ne la veulent parce que vous ne
saviez pas ça c'est aussi la deuxième
c'est aussi un des gros challenge qu'on
a eu c'est qu'on voulait tourner dans
les langues de des personnages qu'on
filmait on voulait pas parce qu'il
parlait évidemment anglais également il
parle djouba arabique mais il parle
aussi la langue de lors de leurs tribus
respectives et on voulait respecter ça
aussi c'est un vraiment un très
difficile donc on tournait sans savoir
ce qu'il disait alors et ça ça a été
assez compliqué donc grâce à forrest
whitaker
donc hic est donc ce film met en valeur
le travail de son ong vous avez pu
présenter ce film à cannes j'imagine une
grande fierté d'autant que documentaire
c'est pas vraiment un jour qu'on voit
beaucoup et avis aux distributeurs qui
nous regardent ça exactement est là il
ya vraiment c'est un pays qui est très
très peu représentées donc avoir un film
comme ça c'est une chance il a fallu six
ans pour le faire donc ça veut dire que
c'est extrêmement compliqué savent ce
film est vraiment un regard sur le
sud-soudan qu'on a qu'on a jamais vu
encore et puis il ya des belles
histoires et c'est effectivement un beau
parti pris que celui de la vertu et de
la lumière dans ces heurts parfois
sombre merci beaucoup d'être venus et
nous en parlait thomassin a donc deux
side of peace au nom de la paix ça c'est
ma traduction je sais pas si ça vaut
combien la production
française n'a pas encore rien apporté
merci encore versé très bonne journée à
bientôt notre